you make money you wanna know the whole
story how I got rich yeah it's a really
long story the point is I've always had
that fire inside of me I've always had
that desire inside of me I think every
man is born with a masculine fire it's
certainly the reason why so many things
in history happen that fire has been
dampened it's been dampened by
Distraction and consumption and all
these things but for me I think the fact
that I was so broke I couldn't really
distract myself I couldn't consume
anything I couldn't buy me like so what
do you do is either a life crime or a
life of punching people in the face and
get paid for it so I chose to get paid I
could feel all these little triggers my
whole life with the system trying to
oppress me and every single person I saw
living the life I was aspiring to was
Outsiders now I considered myself
outside I'm outside the Matrix I can say
what I want you need to be fired go get
me fired anyone who's triggered by this
get me fired good luck I love living
outside the system I always Aspire for
it that's the simple answer